hey everyone in today's video I'm going
to show you how to create this awesome
film burn effect so let's get
[Music]
started hey everyone my name is Cameron
with motion science and I'm super happy
to have you with me here today as I show
you how to create this really cool film
burn effect uh I saw this online I got
really inspired by it so I thought I'd
try to recreate something like it and
that's what we're going to do today
before we get started I do want to
remind you I have a free PDF guide over
at motion science.
tvguide it's my organic guide to motion
cinematic motion design and it's awesome
it's chalk full of tips and tricks for
workflows that I use in my own work so
if you want to create cinematic motion
design like you see in my work
definitely go over and check it out
download it it's absolutely free motion
science.
tvguide let's jump into After Effects
let me show you how we're going to
create this so first things first I have
a comp setup here it's just a night 1920
x 1080 comp uh 8 seconds long that
doesn't really matter what I have here
is a photo that I downloaded uh from a
stock site I rotated it so it's vertical
and it's just got a film strip Edge and
some skateboards in the Middle with some
shoes and then over the top of that I
put some type just says film burn that's
just to get more of an effect that I'm
looking for so we can see the type kind
of squash and stretch and things like
that also I parented the type by
clicking right here and dragging it to
the skateboard and then to the
skateboard if I hit P for position I
separated these uh two position key
frames so let me show you how I did that
so if
I click right here you're going to see
this is how it looks normally if I right
click and say separate dimensions then I
have X and Y and then under y I can
alter option click and I can type in
wiggle parentheses 18 comma 3 and what
this tells After Effects is 18 times per
second I want the film strip to move up
and down by three pixels so by doing
that we get this little tiny jump like
we see here like a like a film projector
would look like right it's got the
little movement up and down so that's
all that is very simple next if I take
this skateboard into a pre-m there we go
and let's call this uh filmb
Bur cck okay and then we're going to
bring in some film footage I have here
from a stock site which is some burn
footage so we'll scale this down to
about
52% and if I end my
composition well let's do about 3
seconds so put in for in bracket and you
can see this is what the footage looks
like it's keyed over
green so we need to remove the green so
that's the first step so I'll go up here
to
effect ke and we'll select key
light and we'll take this dropper here
and select the
green and you can see
immediately it's keyed over the
skateboard image so next thing we're
going to do is we're going to tell the
skateboard we're going to put the
skateboard on top here and we're going
to tell it to track matat the film burn
footage and we're also going to set the
mode to screen you're going to see here
what happens is as the film burn goes
across the screen it wipes out our
footage inside of it let's also go ahead
and turn our film burn footage back on
so we can see it there so now you can
see it's getting a little bit more
interesting right let's go ahead and
duplicate the film burn below it and to
this footage we are going to apply the
effect Sapphire es glow now you can use
any glow you want here this is just a
personal preference of mine and this
this is a preset that I've added just so
I can get some glowing edges here so the
reason I did this with the glow is to
give this Edge a little bit of burn
feeling to it like it's burning the edge
of it right and you can see it right
through here if I turn this
off it just looks more like a black Edge
and just adding this other layer below
it with a glow gives it a little bit of
a burn to it so that's looking awesome
and we're also going to go ahead and set
the top layer to
screen so again and it's burning through
just a little bit more there so that's
with screen and this is normal so you
can see it just creates a little bit
more of a light burn look to
it awesome now here comes the fun part
here's the part where makes look like
the film is actually burning what we
need to do is we need to select our
skateboard pre-m and we're going to go
up
to effect distort
liquefy and we're going to select this
first brush here open up tool options
and we're going to increase the size
here all the way to 600 and then we're
just going to start
draging and
liquefying the image
below so I'm going to kind of speed
through this but you can see it's just
click and drag click and
drag and I'm moving it all to the left
because the the burn is moving up into
the left
then I'm going to open up the
liquefy Distortion percentage I'm going
to crank this up to about 125 set a key
frame and move back
[Music]
here somewhere in
here around 19 set this down to
zero and let's go ahead and ease
in and we'll go ahead and also ease out
so if I skip through
this you can see how it's starting to
warp and create this film burning effect
so let's go ahead and preview this and
here's what the preview looks like and
you can really see that warp just really
sells the effect here we can take this
even a step further um by adding a
camera so that's what we're going to do
we're going to add a camera here we're
going to make these layers 3D and layer
new camera and we're going to make it
one node hit P for
position set a key frame move forward
one frame and we're going to move it
forward just like that and I'll go ahead
and zoom in here so you can see
this so right now it just it pops in
just like we see here we're going to
make this a hold key frame so toggle
hold key frame and we're going to move
forward and at this point we're just
going to make it kind of slide
to the side so if we preview this pops
in and then it kind of moves Pops to the
right and then we can do one more thing
to finish this off we're going to bring
in this light leak we have here we're
going to set it to
screen and we're going to go to effect
color correction CC toner which I
absolutely
love we're going to change the midtone
to a
yellow and let's play it back and there
we go there is our film burn effect the
light leak that happens I timed it
originally so it happens right Pops in
right here and then that's where the
camera Pops in so it kind of also helps
kind of sell that effect and then burn
through so there is our film burn effect
super easy to create an After Effects uh
if you like what you see here I highly
encourage you to download my free pdf
guide over at motion science. tvguide as
always thanks for watching and I will
see you guys in the next
video
[Music]
I